patrick bach angbo chercheur en droit
public et sociologues
bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors ni les vacances ni la
chaleur ni locaux vides 19 n'aura eu la
peau des gilet jaune
ils ont repris le chemin des
ronds-points et les manifestations ont
repris
comment expliquer que ce mouvement de
contestation né en novembre 2018 elle
soit toujours actif après tout ce temps
bonsoir le mouvement des gilet jaune
quand j'ai eu l'occasion de les dire sur
vos antennes dans certaines fois c'est
un mouvement qui s'inscrit dans la durée
ces départs un mouvement ponctuelle les
revendications étaient caractérisées au
début par une certes été cristallisée au
début par une forte contestation contre
les mesures de hausse des prix du
carburant mais aussi une écologie
punitive que certains avaient ressenti
mais aussi la baisse de la vitesse sur
les routes nationales
mais aujourd'hui ce mouvement se veut un
mouvement dans la durée dans la durée
d'abord pour faire face à un pouvoir
politique qui est face à keane est
facilement qui est presque seul sur
l'île qui occupent le terrain presque
seul ce qui n'a pas vraiment de
répondant au plan politique de manière
pleine et qui doit faire face
directement contestation soit de la
population soit des corps intermédiaires
c'est à dire les syndicats comme on l'a
vu en décembre dernier voilà pourquoi
les gilets jaunes ne peuvent passer des
baisses débattre pavés et dans le
contexte actuel la crise économique liée
à l'épidémie de kovy 19 les discours des
gilets jaunes a un retentissement
beaucoup plus important que d'ordinaire
parce que tout le monde sait que la
population française va être sévèrement
concernés par les retombées économiques
notamment financiers et en termes
d'emploi pour les salariés mais aussi en
ce qui concerne la politique sociale et
le gouvernement sur ce plan a montré
bien sûr de la volonté mais simplement
les discours de gilet jaune prend tout
son sens à partir du moment où le
gouvernement est amené à courir un petit
peu derrière la cour derrière la crise
afin de pouvoir pallier
les difficultés économiques auxquelles
font face les français alors sur fond de
crise sanitaire liée aux kobe 19 la
france comme de nombreux autres pays a
restreint certaines libertés notamment
celle de manifester
la préfecture de police de paris
interdit désormais tout rassemblement de
plus de 10 personnes si les gestes
barrière ne sont pas respectées certains
estiment que cette mesure a pour but de
bloquer une rentrée sociale qui
s'annonce mouvementée qu'en pensez vous
ça peut être dans ce sens puisqu'il faut
il faut dénoter un petit peu une sorte
d'anachronisme dans l'action du sur des
contradictions notoire dans l'action de
la préfecture de police de paris le même
jour ou en étant là en étant
l'obligation du port du masque dans les
rues et dans les quartiers de paris
c'est maintenant plus de 60% de paris
qui est consolidée paris qui est
concerné par l'obligation du port du
masque
le même jour on autorise une
manifestation sachant pertinemment que
les gestes barrière né seront pas
respectées puisque il est très difficile
de respecter les gestes barrière dans
une manifestation qui est dynamique
lorsqu'on est statique ça peut se
comprendre ça peut se faire
mais lorsqu'on est dans une position
dynamique c'est-à-dire on s'est déplacé
difficile d'encadrer les gens dans ce
domaine là est la réponse de la
préfecture de police et fossiles à
comprendre dans le sens où le préfet a
et didier lallement a été sévèrement
critiqué par son action à cause de son
action qui était une action anti preuves
précises pour qui était une action sans
c'est un petit peu occupé le terrain
découragé les manifestants aient essayé
parfois des ars et les d'une certaine
manière afin de pouvoir faire échec à
toute tentative de détendre les
mouvements sociaux dans la capitale
c'est aussi un petit peu une politique
ambiguë à laquelle se livre la
préfecture de police de paris
mais on n'est pas dupe pour comprendre
que la rentrée sociale serra très très
mouvementée surtout à partir du moment
où les chiffres du chômage les chiffres
réels pas les récents mais les chiffres
réels vont tomber à la rentrée c'est à
dire dès le mois de septembre et qu'on
connaîtra toutes les catastrophes au
plan c économique les aussi hanté
d'emplois que l'épidémie d'e.coli 19
aura causé alors beaucoup de gilet jaune
estime ne pas être suffisamment voire
pas du tout entendu par emmanuel macron
et son gouvernement
il estime qu'il ya aujourd'hui une vraie
fracture entre la classe dirigeante et
une partie de la population dont ils
font partie
votre analyse sur le sujet vous êtes
d'accord
oui parce que leur discours est un petit
peu parfois pris de manière on peut dire
légère ou d'une manière un petit peu
déconcertant si je prends l'exemple par
exemple si je prends l'exemple du riq le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne
le président du sénat gérard larcher a
repris l'idée selon lui en disant qu' il
n'est pas question du rich or est dans
le système démocratie représentative
tels que la vème république l'a conçu
mais simplement quand il ya une des
pétitions qui atteignent un certain
nombre de votes ça peut faire l'objet
d'une loi qui serait traité en premier
lieu au sénat avant d'être envoyé à
l'assemblée nationale ça n'a aucun sens
en réalité puisque ça veut dire
simplement que la population doit de
toute façon dépendre des cellules or les
gilets jaunes veulent une participation
directe ce qu'on appelle la démocratie
participative aux décisions les plus
importantes du pays et les gilet jaune
veulent aussi avoir la possibilité de
peser sur les animateurs des
institutions parce que les institutions
elles-mêmes mais sur leurs animaux et l
alliance animateurs avoir la possibilité
de révoquer certains qui sont présentés
comme ne pas faire leur travail
correctement
mais il jusque là force est de constater
que deux ans presque deux ans après le
début du mouvement de gilet jaune
il n'y a pas de réponse concrète
concernant les revendications de gilet
jaune et c'est ce que nous avons essayé
nous à l'université paris saclay
l'université d'evry val d'essonne de
traiter dans un ouvrage récent qui est
sorti les gilets jaunes au prisme du
droit dans lesquels je signe un chapitre
intitulé gilet jaune et l'égalité
territoriale donc dans cet ouvrage nous
reprenons un petit peu les
revendications du pardon
pidement s'il vous plaît enfin oui ce
pardon c'est justement pour présenter
les révendications gilet jaune en termes
juridiques et comment les traduire
justement des réponses concrètes au plan
législatif et au plan réglementaire très
que bas congo merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur en droit public et sociologue
également merci beaucoup